[Music]
hello and welcome back to uh
chess openings explained i almost said
the road to 2000
how dare i um today on
chess openings explained i wanted to
continue the fun
in my f3 nimzo series last week we
kicked it off
with what is the most common line that i
face
and a lion that is i think just
objectively better
for white in fact i was watching um some
coverage of the speed chess championship
going on over the past few days and you
know i saw some incredibly strong grand
master jan gustafsson
say something similar about that
structure just being good for white
so it's nice to you know get some
validation watching these these
top-level opening theoreticians
uh sort of confirm what i'm trying to
figure out on my own here
but today i wanted to continue
with the move 4d5 by black
and this time we're going to take a look
at a much tougher nut
to crack by the players with the black
pieces you know they don't necessarily
have to play into this structure
that does turn out to give white an
advantage in most cases so
let's take a look at how that goes i
wanted to start off as i did last time
this time just with one of my own games
from
the past year i feel like starting off
with these gives you a good idea of what
it actually looks like
when you know players like myself and
players at the class level or maybe
expert level
are playing uh playing these positions
with both colors so let's see what line
we're going to talk about today
we have d4 knight f6 c4 e6
knight c3 bishop b4 f3 and again
this move for d5 and today i'm going to
cover
the second main option for black that
you can go for
after committing to this move d5 on move
four
white should still play a3 as we talked
about in the last lecture captures
captures and then last lecture we spent
some time
talking about king's side castles here
as well as c5
but in both lines after c takes d5 we
looked at the slightly dubious in my
opinion
e takes d5 and then this is sort of a
structure
with this pawn either on f2 or f3 to be
honest that
does tend to favor white as we saw in
some specific lines last week
now though we are going to look at the
much more testing knight takes
d5 and of course this is a move that you
cannot play after castles
because here this knight is actually
going to end up a little bit stuck
white has a very interesting tactic that
goes e4
sacrificing the c3 pawn and then after
queen b3
this knight finds itself with no
retreating squares queen takes d4 the
only hope
but this runs into bishop b2 pinning
this way
queen e3 is an attempt to un-pin but
after the important
bishop e2 this knight again will find
itself stuck
knight d5 the only way to unpin and then
miraculously
king f2 knight c2 rook c1
and finally we have captured this knight
so
interesting tactic to know here notably
in my experience you don't have to
memorize this entire line
just remember that if your opponent
castles you can take on d5 and now they
have to take e takes d5
because if they take knight takes d5 e4
wins the game that's really all i keep
stored up here
in my small head the rest you can sort
of figure out over the board
and just understand that this knight
should be trapped if you find the right
moves
the only real trick is that after queen
e3 check you cannot play
knight e2 because then in the main line
here
this knight is going to trade itself off
for the bishop on f1 and you'll find
yourself with
with two fewer pawns than your opponent
so got to be careful there
what is all of this to say the point is
today we are looking at the move
6c5 and knight takes d5 you cannot play
knight takes d5
after castles for this reason now of
course the key difference
is that this line is nowhere close to
working for white because c takes d4
will cement this knight and a huge
advantage for black
so here white is unable to play e4
but what can white do well there's a
slightly unintuitive move
that sometimes shows up in all of these
openings where black is playing
in early c5 and that move is d take c5
this is sort of the move that you'll see
occur i think a lot at the
amateur level at the beginner level
especially you know you take one look at
that pawn on c5 and you say well that
pawn's not defended why can't i take it
and this is one of the slightly rarer uh
occasions where it is actually correct
to capture this pawn
um why isn't it normally correct well
normally
black is able to recapture this pawn a
little bit later for example with the
dark squared bishop or with the knights
but here white can actually make it a
little bit awkward for black
to regain this material fully uh black's
best move and really the only
uh well actually there's two moves here
but the best move in my opinion is queen
a5
attacking the c3 pawn and the c5 pawn
what's the other move
uh you ask well hold on a little bit
it's the move f5 which we will
definitely get to
but first the main line queen a5 and
here it looks like
white's actually in a bit of a tough
spot but you can in fact
just uh evict this knight now with e4 by
capturing on c5
taking away this option for uh black
now once again you can force this knight
to move out of the way
why not knight take c3 well the move
queen d2
is is simply quite good for white
why is this quite good for white well if
you think you're gonna take this
bishop b2 and this knight is once again
a little bit stuck bishop g7 for example
rick c8 uh is coming in short order
and black will have to resign this game
so
knight takes c3 not really playable
queen takes c3 is a check
but then bishop d2 and keep an eye on
these lines because they
will start to look a little bit familiar
when we talk about the f5 move
that is an occasion when this queen
takes c3 move will be a bit more
relevant
but here once again this is just going
to be a very pleasant position
for white bishop c3 and once again
there's trouble on the c file if you
think you're going to take the c5 pawn
there's trouble on the g7 square and
white is just much better here
so enough talk of all these silly little
sidelines the point is e4
it looks as though that this pawn on c3
is hanging
but in this case it's not that big of a
deal it's not
really hanging and here we're going to
talk about two different moves
knight e7 and knight f6 are the two main
options
for black just both natural retreating
knight moves knight c7 is kind of a move
but in my opinion it just doesn't really
make sense you can play
similarly to how you would play against
knight e7 or knight f6
and the knight on c7 in my opinion is
just badly placed so not really going to
touch on that too much but here
my opponent played the main move knight
e7 and now you can simply go bishop e3
and this is now just a sacrifice of the
c3 pawn if your opponent wants to take
it
again though this is not going to be a
pawn your opponent really should be
taking
in this case though there's no direct
refutation as in the other cases with an
early bishop c3 or anything
it's just that this pawn isn't really
worth the time
it takes to capture with the queen this
queen is going to have to
leave a little bit later on white can
develop naturally
and now white's bishops will start to
exert their pressure on the queen's side
with that in mind knight d7 is the move
that my opponent chose to play in the
game
and it's not really the main move so
i was officially out of theory at this
point in time
so let's take this opportunity to get
sort of a feeling for the position
right this is of course a game i played
over the board my opponent was rated
around 1950
uh at the time and you know you're out
of theory in this position
let's examine some of these the ideas
right so white for the moment does have
an extra pawn
on c5 and the c3 pawn is is still
hanging
so the next move is you know pretty
natural you just go queen b3
and defend this pawn on c3 and white now
has a really interesting idea
if black thinks they can take this pawn
just sort of outright so what should
uh what should white be doing if black
thinks they can just capture this pawn
on c5 regaining the material what do you
think chad
mayor says cool chest shirt how do you
get one you come to the st
louis chess club and you buy it
these are for sale okay
queen b5 check not quite uh white's
really
a critical move here is actually the
strange looking queen b4
you uh quite simply are forking black's
pieces
right it's not the most standard kind of
fork that you would
ever expect to find but the point is the
only way out of this
for black is to just capture on b4 but
this is going to fix
white's pawn structure either pawn
capture is actually quite
good for white here in fact this is
probably just immediately winning
another pawn back
so keep this queen before idea in mind
it often
makes the thread of knight take c5 a
little bit of a paper tiger
whereas if you can get queen b4
and even if this tactic to win a pawn
didn't exist c takes b4
white would be doing very very well here
with the two open bishops
easy development and a totally fixed
pawn structure
so someone in the chat says this pawn
structure is terrible and
for the moment that's true but it's okay
to have a terrible pawn structure when
you have more pawns
that's that's kind of the gist of it so
my opponent goes knight c6
which is fine and i continued with a4
now my opponent having stopped queen b4
uh
decided that knight takes c5 was
playable now and he was correct
i go queen a3 though using the space
that was
made by pushing this a pawn then it
comes back to d7
and now after simple development white
is is simply better in this position
why is that well let's take a look my
opponent goes queen
d8 why does my opponent go queen d8 well
because this queen on a3 is surprisingly
powerful
and black's king is is simply stuck in
the center
so uh over the board at the class level
play
it's not even move 15 yet and once again
white
has a strong advantage as white often
does in the f3 nimzo if the opponent is
unprepared
so now my opponent starts making some
concessions to try to castle
i just continue developing the pieces
out knight c6
fractures the pawn structure now queen
d6 takes over the dark squares
and my opponent goes knight back to b8
and this is rather striking
rather striking my opponent had
developed two pieces
they're both now dead and the remaining
pieces on their starting squares
and the game didn't last too much longer
i think
my opponent ran into some some quick
trouble here
on the king's side and lost material and
lost the game not too quickly
uh not not too slowly after um
just checks and we don't need to look at
this this isn't relevant to the lecture
just the poor guy rook takes h5 final
move of the game
and that was the the match if you take
this
check check
check tough tough tough tough so what
happened this game it looked like black
just developed white developed
black tried to regain this pawn and then
everything sort of
went when a foul for for black after
this move knight d7
black's king was stuck in the center and
white was was quickly winning
and that's a story that can kind of go
either way
in this variation on the surface level
it actually doesn't look
too dangerous for either side right you
know you sort of develop out
white has this messy messy messy pawn
structure
but the character of the game is
basically white tries to make it
so that recapturing this pawn is a bad
idea for black
and black will be fully equal if he does
uh manage to capture this pawn back on
c5 so
in this case i succeeded in making
knight take c5 a bad move for black and
for that reason
when my opponent did play knight takes
c5 uh
he had a worse position in this case so
that's sort of the reason why i wanted
to show you
this game uh the character of this line
in my opinion is if black can take back
on c5 with no problems then black is
doing totally totally fine and if white
isn't careful
might be better but if white can either
maintain this pawn
or get some other advantage after knight
takes c5
then white is is gonna be a bit better
so let's see what that looks like on the
theoretical
level now now that we've seen what it
looks like in an over the board game
that i have played
let's see what it looks like at that top
level at the
opening theory level with players you
know coming very well prepared
and for that i want to start off in the
same line we just looked at the knight
e7 line
but with players of a bit higher
strength that is
lee chao and yaakovenko
so let's take a look at how these
players did it by the way this game i
should scroll down
is from the geneva grand prix in 2017. i
know this helps ben simon a lot when i
just say that out loud
so d4 uh by lee chow knight f6
and we get into our main variation here
bishop b4
f3 d5 a3 takes takes
c5 once again c takes d5 e takes d5
would be the first lecture we're talking
about knight takes d5
and again e4 allows knight takes now so
we go
dc5 and once again f5 is playable we'll
talk about that later
but the main move is queen a5 now e4
knight c3 means queen d2 queen c3 means
bishop d2
so knight either to f6 or e7
bishop e3 developing and defending once
again queen takes c3 leads to an
advantage for white after king f2
white's pieces are just too active and
the pawn structure is
is fine for white there so the main move
is castle's king side
notably not what my opponent did with
this knight d7 move
it is a good thing in fact to castle the
king
for black it turns out you know that's
why my opponent sort of lost in the
first game
didn't get castled but here yaakov knows
what he's doing and castles the king
once again though this move queen b3 is
the right idea for white so you can sort
of see how
even when my opponent deviated a little
bit these
theoretical moves the moves that that
we're learning here today are still
going to be
the guiding factor so queen
b3 and now rather than go with a simple
move like 97
we saw that this is sort of an empty
threat because white has this queen b4
idea fork and queen and knight
so the slightly paradoxical looking
queen c7
is actually the right idea for black in
this case
why queen c7 well now you can in fact
make a legitimate threat
to capture this pawn on c5 also queen
before
on its own may may have been a useful
tempo to gain at some point later in
later in life for black now there are a
couple
reasonable moves for white but the move
i
am going to recommend here and i did do
some digging into all of these
is bishop b5 and
uh i think from what i could tell
if white plays very very well uh then i
think black may not be fully equalizing
here uh
it's possible that's you know in some of
these lines if both players play
perfectly
black is is equalizing it feels like
black should be equalizing because this
is some of the main line theory
but in every line that i was looking at
i uh i was finding
small advantages at the very least for
for whites
or just some tricky positions for black
that you have to play near perfectly
to uh to survive so why bishop b5 why
not bishop c4 why not bishop d3 why not
bishop e2 well bishop b2 is obvious
you want to bring the knight here why
not bishop d3 well the bishop
actually just doesn't do anything on
this square right it's looking at this
e4 pawn
not the most useful piece in the world
and it also might be a target after move
like rook d8
why not bishop c4 well it turns out one
of black's main
ideas is to bring this knight to a5 and
start attacking these leg squares
be a little bit awkward for white to
have the queen on b3 and the bishop on
c4
a little bit susceptible to to some
forks
so we get bishop b5 right and this move
has another purpose
as well white is sometimes looking to
actually trade off this bishop
for one of these knights why is that
well these knights
are the way uh the path for black to
recapturing on c5 and that's going to be
a little bit more difficult
if one of them is missing also these
knights
may create some very tangible threats of
attacking these light squares
for white so sometimes it is again just
useful for white to get rid of this
bishop
for the knight to help preserve this
extra pawn
um here in our main game we
are going to look at the move knight e
to c6 now this position after bishop b5
has been reached over 100 times
and knight e to c6 is played in in
almost every game
it's played 92 out of 118 i think by the
math i'm using
but i wanted to give a brief honorable
mention
to e5 so e5 is a sort of tricky move
for black that we're going to take a
look at
why we're going to take a look at it
because if you were watching the 2020
u.s championship very closely
you would recognize this position from a
game between sam shankland with the
white pieces and wesley so with black
and how that game continued was knight
e2
bishop e6 uh c4
this knight came to c6 knight c3
knight a5 queen b4 this knight comes out
to e6
and all of a sudden you start to see
this light squared pressure that i was
talking about and it turns out
wesley was was quite frankly outplaying
sam in this particular opening
wesley was taking over these light
squares and sam was really really
relying on a knight d5 move to help save
the day
but with active play wesley just made
sure sam never got it
how did he do that after bishop takes c6
the unfortunate knight takes c4 cam
and now the light squares were falling
to wesley so
in this game in the u.s championship so
this is a horror story
if you saw this game and that you
probably never want to play the f3 nimzo
because sam just got demolished in this
game
there was a little bit of back and forth
but sam was just losing
out of the opening and this is the risky
run in this particular variation if you
allow the opponent's bishop to come out
to e6
you allow this knight to a5 then odds
are
you might be getting busted why is that
well you've got some
looseness around your king and black's
pieces are going to be very very well
placed
with this control over the light squares
you just can't give up this much
control of your own position so how do
you prevent it
well the trick is to do what
a non does in these positions so let's
take a look at how anand
treated this position in a slightly
different move order so wesley tried
this move e5 first and foremost
but let's see uh how it continues in the
main line knight ec6 first
knight e2 natural development e5 here is
what was played in our main game
king's side castles bishop earned knight
a5
queen b4 and now seemingly bishop e6
is achieving something very very very
similar to what
wesley so was getting against sam
shanklin right we have the bishop on a6
we have the knight on a5 and if we play
something like c4 it is actually true we
would be getting something
much like what sam shanklin got in fact
this may
just be in almost identical position
somehow though i think
white is even down an extra tempo here
so
what's the trick why would a nod allow
this position uh what do you think chat
what should white
play in this position what can be done
here
we looked at this game on twitch when i
did a recap of the us
championship but it is very very
relevant to this opening theory lecture
as well
so
what can white do
what's to be done well
white should play rook a b one yeah
moves like rook a b one you know
maybe they they don't lose off the bat
maybe uh white is
is doing okay but white can get a very
very solid advantage
by playing like vishy and on with the
incredible sacrifice
knight d4 um this is the way to
regain these light squares against
bishop e6 and knight a5
now in my opinion if
black is just getting the bishop to e6
and the knight to a5
and invading on these light squares
white is going to be worse
so this should sort of be priority
number one
in your head if you're playing against
this opening
or this this type of setup from black if
you allow black
everything that they want here with
these light squares
then you are in serious serious danger
of being worse if you play something
nonchalant like rookie b1
um i i don't think you're really losing
the game this knight's going to come to
a6
you should probably take this piece
queen a4
but you know you start looking at things
like knight c4
and you start asking yourself what am i
what am i doing here
why why am i playing this opening right
um
so always always always have this bishop
e6 idea in mind and have something ready
for it now let's take a look at this
knight d4
idea um luckily i don't think
you need to have the deepest theoretical
knowledge
you know memorized moves for this just
as long as you understand knight d4
is an idea and why it's an idea then
that should usually be enough here
what is the idea well in vishyananda
against huang hao
we saw e takes d4 c takes d4 and white
is simply
uh you know crashing through the center
with a too many pawns just too many
pawns
too many pawns to count in that game we
saw knight bc6 the simple queen c3 you
don't really need to rush things with
white here
um knight e7 was the choice for black
now arc f to d1 white just supports
these pawns from behind
and you really don't feel the extra
piece for black right these knights
are totally discombobulated this bishop
is going to be useless after pawn d5
notably by the way white did not play d5
here
why is that well black's really only
equalizing try
is is to sacrifice the piece back and
vishi's not even giving him that he's
saying no
you will not take two pawns for a piece
i will keep my pawns thank you very much
rick 88 bishop f2 uh a6
and now bishop g3 and the game just
went very far south very quickly
um with black sacrificing back
uh some pieces there and ending up up
the exchange
uh with one fewer pawn to worry about
but this was a very good advantage for
white and anon did go on to win
back in 2011 at tata steel
um just to show you some moves this is
what happened this d-pawn
was the story of the game along with
this a pawn and here uh wong hao simply
resigned
so i just wanted to make sure everybody
knew
this idea of knight d4 this is a great
way to fight against this bishop e6 plan
for um for black right keep this one in
mind because if you do allow bishop
e6985 you are in serious serious danger
of being worse
uh with that in mind bishop e6 is not
the most common move here
uh why is that well knight d4 is simply
better for white as
vishyanan demonstrated and as players
have have come to learn at the top
at the top level so rather than bishop
e6
everybody and their grandmother is
playing knight a6 here these days
uh what's the point the point is you
attack two pieces at the same time
terrifying so what should white do in
this position well it is time to give up
this bishop for one of those knights
with bishop takes a6
now b takes a6 only move and
in the game i think leech out was doing
a really good job of keeping up the
pressure here so
what is this position right well we have
very much the same dynamic
we had last time black truly did make
you know sort of concession by doubling
the pawns here but what's black's idea
well it's it's the exact same idea we
were looking at before bishop e6
and knight c4 and even here after b
takes e6 if you're allowing this knight
into c4
into b3 into these squares white's gonna
be worse you just
you can't let them do it you can't let
them do this to you
okay don't just don't let them so leech
out has the right idea here
to stop bishop b6 knight c4 at all costs
and he goes
rook a to d1 how does this stop bishop
e6
well again we don't see knight d4 in
this case
with knight d4 unfortunately i think
ignoring it may be the best idea for
black
and they would still be getting these
light squares
notably in the previous position we had
a bishop on b5 preventing this
but rook d5 again cutting off these
light squares
sacrificing material in order to get
very mobile
very fluid pawns and i think this does
in fact
still grant white an advantage uh in the
game
we saw rook f to b8s queen a4
bishop takes d5 finally e takes d5
and now rook b5 is the only move for
black to try to
defend and then i think lee chao
actually lets uh jakovenko off the hook
a little bit here with the slightly
nonchalant
rook d1 the game very quickly fizzled
out
rook c5 sacrificing the material back
bishop takes queen takes
and after some moves the game was agreed
a draw
nothing too crazy okay maybe this game
was a little crazier than i gave her
credit for
but not the kind of crazy we're looking
for right why why are we allowing black
to threaten checkmate
so i don't actually like how lee chow
handled this position
with rook d1 here so white in my opinion
has a much stronger idea available
and that idea is to go not rook d1 but
rather
d6 now what does d6 do well it attacks a
queen
right queen c6 now is the only move for
black and now if we go c4 essentially
forcing
rook takes c5 we actually have a better
move here than bishop takes c5
and it's a move that should be familiar
to you guys in the chat room
so what did we do last time black took
our c5 pawn yeah that's right
we forked him with queen b4 and the
exact same idea
is actually just uh very very good here
for white knight b7 actually loses the
game
to rook b1 uh with a threat to the
knight if you go rook b8 there's a pin
on the b
file so the only move here for black to
keep the game going is rook takes c4
and now rather than winning an exchange
back we actually win a full
piece and after queen takes d6 i really
i very much think it's white who's going
to be putting on the pressure in this
end game you have two pieces for a rook
and technically two pawns but one of
those pawns is here on a6
and the other one is not super
threatening here on e5
either and i think it's very much weight
for choice in this endgame although
black
should have very strong holding chances
but i think this is the black
the best that black can get in these uh
these positions here so we went pretty
deep we're on move 24 at this point
but the point i'm trying to get at is
always
always always be looking to prevent
bishop e6
and a knight to these light squares this
is the main main idea
in this uh most popular line against the
f3 nimzo
in the in the knight takes c5 variation
that is and
you you just have to stop it you just
have to stop knight c4
but the good news is you have all these
various tactical resources
you know sort of uh at hand right you
should be comfortable
sacrificing a little bit of material in
order to get some mobile pawns
and then if you play well odds are
you're going to have a little bit of an
edge in those positions so
what uh how did we get here let's recap
e4
knight f6 is a move which we're going to
talk about next but we focused on 97
first
bishop e3 castles queen b3 queen c7
sort of the only moves here then i'm
recommending this move
bishop b5 uh challenging these knights
a little bit more directly now everybody
plays
knight e to c6 but we took a quick look
at e5
and that was played against sam shanklin
by wesley so
and here 92 e5 now trying to get bishop
e6
with knight a5 castles a5 queen b4
now knight a6 bishop a6 ba6
and the key idea by lee chao to stop
knight c4 is rooked e1
rook d5 and this turns out to give white
a little bit of a pleasant edge
um okay
uh so by the way if knight a5 here queen
b4
uh knight or e5 castles this is just an
alternate move order
to get to the same position uh i just
figured i should highlight that because
e5 played in the game
is not the most common usually they
start with knight a5 but this doesn't
really
doesn't really change anything so with
all this in mind
let's try and improve for sam shankland
right
this is the position that sam shanklin
was was facing leslie did some
slight move order trickery to get this
bishop out to e6 a little bit more
quickly
and sam as you might remember responded
with this move c4
and this is move got him in quite a bit
of trouble so chat
keeping in mind all of these ideas we
looked at uh
in the lead ciao yakovenko game what's
an improvement
for sam shankland here how can you
improve
uh on sam's move
what do you think what do you think chat
yeah and chess king has it right i think
the simple queen a4
would have been a massive massive
improvement for sam shanklin
why is that well if black is trying
the main idea of knight e to c6 and
knight a5
once again he's running into the idea of
knight d4
when white is going to be better right
just setting up
for this knight d4 idea is very very
good for white in this case
and if wesley tries the simpler approach
of just coming after the pawn
now we can in fact give up this piece
it goes something like queen c2 and the
fact of the matter is
i don't see how black is actually going
to regain this pawn
on c5 anymore and this i think would be
close
to uh to balance but
okay what's the point well the point is
in this 97 variation
the really main main idea for black is
to go e5
bishop e6 and knight a5 and white is
supposed to prevent this
uh at at all costs basically with these
knight d4
with these rook d5 ideas and just start
taking over
start taking over the position from
there all right questions on this knight
e7 move before we move on
to knight f6 time is short so i must go
quickly
all right moving right along bishop c4
should be
okay says uh pip and chuck and yeah
that's that's true as well
in sam shanklin's game after
bishop e6 uh
sorry after bishop b6 here
bishop c4 is is also fine but i think
the most consistent move with what we've
been looking at
is queen a4 right you just keep the
position locked and you still
maintain this idea of knight d4 but okay
let us
move along uh up next i'm going to show
you a game between
sergey volkov and gyorgy timoshenko and
sergey volkov is gonna be a name that
you're gonna be familiar with
if you start looking at games in the f3
nimzo all this guy does
is play games in the f3 nim so like i
i don't know if somehow i'm modeling my
repertoire after sergey volkov but like
every
opening i want to play i like go deep
into the lines and i'm i'm looking at
games by this guy
so somehow someway volkov is gonna gonna
find his way into your life if you keep
playing the f3 nimzo
but this was a very nicely played game
by him that i wanted to take a look at
so let's see what's going on
we have again the uh starting variation
takes takes c5 very important not
castles
c takes d5 knight takes d5 d takes c5
queen a5 and again e4
and now rather than knight e7 black goes
knight f6 in this case
and this move is very very similar to 97
but there are some really key
differences again bishop e3 is the move
for
white we see kingside castles
and now i uh i sort of dug
into all of the various options for uh
for white in this case right the main
move is still this this very natural
queen b3
but after after knight f to d7 you go
down this this sort of
long and arduous arduous line where
at the end of the day this is just all
theory by the way
just all theory queen a5 takes takes
something like knight c6 and then you
choose
rook a2 over rook a1 for some reason and
then there's 95 and then like f4 and
then you do this and d2 is better than
c1 for some reason and then this and
then this and then
it's boring it's so boring i fell asleep
trying to prep this lecture so i am not
going to be recommending
the main line in this case because i
think honestly
this is one of those cases where black
is not worse
if black knows all of this if black is
well prepared
then black is just not going to be worse
if they're playing this line against the
f3 nimso and
that's the truth of any opening in chess
really if black knows what they're doing
you're not going to get an advantage but
what you can do is play something a
little bit more off
beat and make that road to a quality a
little bit less
clear to find so if you're a big theory
monger you might consider playing the
move king f2 here
rather than queen b3 but that line
was still a little bit too theoretical
for me and it feels
almost as if white is taking just as
many risks as black there
so i'm gonna recommend the move that
sergey volkov played in this case
which is the the almost non-existent
knight h3
now what's wrong with knight h3 well
nothing really is is that wrong
with with knight h3 to be honest with
you
and actually uh sorry i should say
in the game volkov played knight h3
first
which i don't totally recommend because
queen takes c3 might actually be good
here
so i am recommending the main move queen
b3 but then after the only real response
net fd7
here i'm recommending knight h3 which
they transposed to in
in the game via the other move order um
but yeah i say go queen b3 first i don't
see a real reason to
to let black take on c3 so just just go
queen b3
all right and then knight h3 and now we
are in this offbeat variation
that's uh that i think is a good try for
white
to to play for an advantage
now this isn't totally unknown there are
something like 17 games here after net
h3 it's a perfectly normal developing
move so of course it's been tried
but the point is you're avoiding this
stupid theory where you push your a pawn
all the way up the board and then trade
the queens
and then just you know keep going and
going and going and going and going
and then black is fine right you're
avoiding all of that you're just
developing your pieces
uh the best move for black has been
played in all 17 games which is again
queen c7 you just step out of this queen
b4
idea and now
sergey volkov chooses the most annoying
way to play which i think
is sometimes the best way to play if
you're going for practical chances
and that is with the move queen c4 it's
not too late
to to white for white to revert to you
know the the old boring stuff with going
a a4 a5 and like this a6 and some sort
of weird pressure on the queen side
where you trade queens
like it's fine for white but it's also
fine for black and it looks boring to me
so i like what sergey did instead he
just goes queen c4
and says i'm gonna defend my pawn right
and this is a pretty different idea
compared to what we were looking at
in the previous games so why are we
doing this
with white here well there's a really
key difference between 97
and knight f6 to d7 and that is on d7
you're not really concerned uh as much
with this bishop e6 idea the knight's
just in the way
of the bishop and so this is no longer
really the main idea
for black so seemingly almost identical
position
where black is going after c5 with the
knights but with this knight on d7
white is no longer really concerned with
bishop b6 and is going to have to be
concerned with some other ideas
instead what ideas are those
well in the game timoshenko goes knight
e5
very tempting move challenging the queen
on c4
simply queen b4 by white now knight b to
c6
is still developing with tempo but now
we we see this queen on a slightly more
familiar square
of a4 um now
i think it's not too late to uh to
equalize with black here
if you choose bishop d7 just putting
this bishop opposite the queen
white can ignore it for the moment and
just develop but after something like
knight a5
knight a c6 honestly it might be in both
players best interests
to to just start repeating the position
if you do want to keep the game going
though
can you can just head back queen a1 and
the game will continue
you play something like a4 queen a2
and once again though uh the main point
is that you do have to be a little bit
worried about this move e5 so
instead of queen a2 something like
bishop b5 and you could get
just a very normal looking position with
something like this
right and again white may have some
winning tries thanks to having this this
extra c pawn
still on the board with pressure down
the b file so that's sort of what you're
aiming for if you want to keep the game
going you can retreat the queen
along the b file and claim that this is
not actually the most
ideal setup of black's minor pieces
in the game though we see knight d7
which is a sort of understandable
mistake
by black right it seems like a pretty
natural move you go knight d7
try to contest the c pawn and that's
that's you know
the point of your opening with this
knight f6 line you go knight f6 you go
knight d7 you attack the pawn
but here this this actually turns out to
give white some advantage
uh white simply develops bishop b5 the
move we've seen before
and now after knight a5 again volkov
plays the most annoying move which is
just queen b4
defending the pawn and after knight c6
now with the bishop on b5 it's a little
bit of a different case
white is not by any means obliged to
repeat
and can actually get a pretty
significant advantage by once again
giving up this bishop you shouldn't
really be afraid to give up this bishop
in this opening line it's all about
preserving this extra pawn on c5
and keeping your space so bishop c6
queen c6 played in the game and now we
just see very natural moves by sergey
rook d1
rook to the center a5 hits the queen
queen d4
why not centralize e5 again hits the
queen
and queen d5 again it'd be a huge
mistake to allow this change in
structure
so queen a4 was played the simple move
castles
and white has a very significant edge in
this case
thanks to the extra pawn and also thanks
to the very well-placed
centralized pieces and so somehow
sergey volkov is getting an advantage in
this game how did he do it
not by force black could have equalized
with this idea of bishop d7 black could
have probably equalized with an earlier
knight a6
but the point is this line keeps the
pieces on the board
keeps the play going and that's why it's
my recommendation here
okay what does knight h3 even do
why not knight e2 or bishop d3 well net
h3 develops and
also doesn't commit this bishop to a
square you would like to have this
bishop on b5 and i'll go back to that
eventually
but knight e2 of course would would be
blocking in the bishop on f1 so that's
why not h3
it avoids all the main theory it
develops a piece and
you know you get to keep pieces on the
board and continue playing chess
let's quickly see how the game finished
black played rook a6
white brings the knight back to the
center and just fast forwarding a little
bit
none of this play was by any means
perfect by these two players
but it's clear to see that white is in
the driver's seat
with pressure on the d file and the b
file
and against the queen and against the e
pawn
and weird maneuvering but at the end of
the day white
does end up winning this game
how does he do it i don't know i didn't
watch the rest of the game to be honest
all i cared about was the opening
advantage ah yeah
he does it with an h pawn look at that
like h pawn super scary
good enough to win a game and
there you go h pawn wins the game only
took
92 moves right so if you want to win a
92 moves
this is the opening for you uh but okay
let's back up just a little bit here
so in the game sergey played knight h3
first
but again the main move is queen b3 and
that is the move i recommend
but not with the main line idea of a4 it
just simplifies too much if your
opponent is playing knight f69d7
i promise you they have looked at this
a4 line this is the main main line
and it's it's a bit too boring for my
taste so i am recommending
knight h3 here keeping pieces on the
board
uh why not play bishop b5 well i think
you can play bishop b5
right away but knight h3 is fine you
come back to f2 control a lot of these
squares
and keep an eye on e4 there was one more
thing i wanted to
mention in these variations
and that is an idea
for black in some cases so
let's back up to something like
this idea of queen b3 knight fd7 and
let's just say we go for this a4 line
queen a3 b6
and let's say you know white plays some
nonchalant move like bishop e2
so there is one active idea that you
very much
want to uh to keep an eye on of course
in this position i guess black can just
retake the pawn here but that idea i
want you to look
out for is the idea of f5 i don't want
you guys to be blindsided by this idea
and something you should keep an eye on
and it's one reason why knight h3
is a pretty reasonable developing move
for
for whites rather than something like
knight e2
the point kind of is that after
some variations let's say
you know something like bishop b5
something like f5
okay well first of all that's that's
here so let's say queen b4
something like this f5 the point now
for white is knight f2 is often a very
good defensive resource
and knight f4 or g5 can be a very good
offensive resource in response to f5 so
that's another sort of hidden reason
why this knight comes to h3 it gives you
a bit more options
against this active idea of f5 for black
it's an important idea
that i wanted to mention why not g4
instead of knight h3
well i don't know if i you know okay g4
is a little silly g4 is a little silly
right uh just just a little silly
you don't need to do this you don't need
to do this the play is mainly on the
queen side
in this case with this extra c pawn and
you're not that worried about f5
that you're going to play g4 here just
develop your pieces
and fight on the queen's side that is
the idea of this variation
so okay any questions on
this mainline stuff of the uh
knight takes d5 line of the nimzo indian
the
these moves 97 and knight f6 the this is
like 90 percent of what you're going to
face against snake takes d5
so any questions here any questions
all right if not i want to move on to
the tricky tricky trick line
with f5
so who better to look at for the tricky
tricky trick line
than mom and yara against wong hao and
this is actually taken from a blitz game
it was the highest rated game i could
really find in this
this line um and the reason for that is
i'm recommending a bit of a sideline
here so even though it's a blitz game
the players did play very very well in
the opening and that's what matters
ignore the result i think mamadiarov
like flagged in a very good position at
the end or something so the result
doesn't really matter
what matters is these players brought
their opening prep to this blitz game
and performed very very well here so
what line am i talking about well
there is sort of a surprise weapon for
black
in this position we see d takes c5
and we spent all the live long day
talking about queen a5
e4 and then this big queen side battle
right it's all about
black trying to regain this pawn white
trying to keep the extra space black
trying to get bishop e6 white preventing
it with tactics right
that's been the main focus of the
lecture so far
but black does have another option that
option is to stop
e4 by playing the move f5 and believe it
or not
uh i think if my memory is serving me
correctly the very first time i played a
grand master
in a classical time control game over
the board i found myself
facing down this f5 move and i had
absolutely no idea
what was going on and no clue zero idea
of what was going on there are many
options for white in this case
knight h3 is the main move queen c2 is
uh the secondary move e4 is actually
playable with the idea of
pawn sacrifice of course takes queen h4
check would be unfortunate
but queen c2 here is is a playable idea
but what i'm going to recommend to you
is the fourth most popular move
because if your opponent is playing f5
odds are they are getting
more games in this position than you are
what do i mean by that
well f5 like i said is very much a
surprise weapon
and what i don't like to recommend
against surprise weapons
like f5 is the main main stuff
against it because what happens in the
main main stuff well
white plays you know all the best moves
for like 10 moves in a row and then may
might be slightly better might even not
in this case
right but players with the black pieces
here because they're gonna get this
position more often than you they're
playing it every time that against the
f3 nimzo
then they're going to be just more
experienced in that main stuff
so i really really like the move mom and
yara played in this case
which is c4 and c4 is a very
interesting idea for white at first
glance it looks like a perfectly natural
move
you want to remove scratching uh
okay sorry about that uh you want to
remove this knight from d5
but of course there's a massive downside
to this and that is that it hangs upon
right and so this is in fact actually
just a pawn sacrifice
by mama yarov and like i said this is
very much not the most common uh
response to this f5 idea for black
and i think that's a really good thing
because you're not going to be getting
this very often
and i found that c4 is a move you can
play without actually memorizing too
much
the play comes pretty pretty naturally i
think so queen h4 check
g3 to get out of check queen takes c4
and the idea is that you do get to play
this move e4
with tempo on the queen and tempo on the
knight and if you remember from earlier
in the lecture i said to keep an eye on
this idea
bishop d2 queen e5 here is where it is
coming up again
right the only difference is in this
case black has a pawn on f5 already
so unlike in the position that i talked
about earlier
white is not just close to winning here
because this pawn on f5 makes a very
very serious difference
right pressuring e4 um it's
kind of funny how it's it's almost
literally identical to the position of
queen c3 bishop d2
uh queen e5 but g3 and f5 have have just
been inserted
uh funny how chess works like that
sometimes so how should we continue
well our pawns attacked we should defend
it with bishop g2
and now fe4 fe4
and it turns out the best line
for black goes something like knight c3
uh when takes takes is not the best
response
for white but you can go queen c1 knight
e4
and then not you know block putting
anything on the e file
but actually just removing the queen
from being in front of your king with
bishop f4
after queen d4 the best move in the
position uh the only real move to not
give white
a significant advantage bishop e3 now if
queen back to e5
we have time to play knight f3 with our
c pun defended
right if we played knight f3 here then
queen c5 was fine for black
but with this inserted then knight f3 is
quite good
white will castle next and life is very
very good for the white pieces
queen d3 however is a bit better knight
e2
and then if something like castles will
go knight f4 and at the end of the day
it's going to be a position with two
bishops for whites
and i think a little bit of an edge in
this case a little bit of an
edge how did white end up getting an
edge in the surprise f5 weapon with
a not popular move well it turns out way
back here
this move queen h4 check while very
seemingly the most natural idea in the
position
is not the best idea in the position i
think after queen h4 check
e4 this very forcing line this is the
only line for black to not lose material
uh the fact of the matter is i think
white is just a little bit better
so what can black do instead well way
back here
better for black than queen h4 is
exploiting this move with c4 in a
slightly different way
how is that well you can exploit the
weakness on this diagonal
with queen f6 and this is the path to
equality
for black here this move queen f6 is
sort of defusing
the c4 idea however i kind of doubt
that uh that your opponents are going to
be so well prepared to be honest i kind
of doubt it
and there's actually another game here
that mom and darf has played against
ivan chuck
and he actually lost that game too i
didn't do too much research
into how that game happened but the best
move here for white is bishop g5
i think in that game mamadiar played
bishop d2 which isn't a very good move
but bishop g5 is the nice sacrificial
idea
for white you are defending this rook
with tempo on the queen
against anything now you are going to
capture on d5
so queen g5 cd5 is best
now in the game e takes d5 was played
and
i uh sorry and now i'm looking at a game
between alianov and somebody with a very
difficult
name to pronounce named mcheadley
mchead michael
and in that game uh i think white found
the best move here uh el elliana with
the white pieces didn't actually take on
d5
because this pawn is is just not a very
good pawn for black and better i think
for white
is to just develop naturally with knight
h3 the queen came to e3
now queen d2 is just untangling for
white
if you take on c5 look out for rook c1
that would be ending the game so d4 was
played instead
now rook d1 is still gaining this d pawn
with a little bit of extra development
knight a6 was played takes takes takes
takes e3 bishop d7
bishop c4 96 was played in the game
takes takes king d2 and this is this is
just equality
uh not gonna lie to you and say white is
winning by force in this sideline of the
f3n so that nobody ever plays
um it's a sideline for a reason right c4
black can equalize with this move
f uh queen f6 but you know the road to
get there
is not exactly trivial right there's a
lot of places where black can go wrong
here
and in particular the most commonly
played move the most natural move
queen h4 check the point of f5 in many
cases
is i think leading to an advantage for
white in this
line that we talked about with g3 takes
e4
bishop g2 and here knight c3 being the
best move
still doesn't fully equalize thanks to
queen c1 and bishop
f4 now in the game black played the very
very natural
king side castles however i think this
is even worse for black
than knight c3 is why is that well white
simply just develops their pieces
knight e2 played in the game this knight
is now actually hanging so knight f6 was
played
and here white just castled king's side
but i believe the move bishop f4 is
close to game ending
again you can't take on c5 because of
bishop d6 in this case
queen a5 check is met with the bishop
and white picks up in exchange
and basically what you would get is the
game position except white gets to keep
their c
pawn in the game mom and nirv castled
and black is equalizing
after queen takes c5 you know just a
pawn
for the activity that white is gonna get
with the bishops
and uh and black is doing fine here but
had white played bishop f4
this is effective enough at defending
the c-pawn
and then white can castle and you
essentially get the same position
with none of the compensation for black
and white would
i think be significantly better in in
this case
so what do you need to know about this
f5 move well
you need to remember that this move c4
is a good
offbeat option to sort of combat this
idea after queen h4 check
you block and just play the natural
moves attack both pieces
block the check defend your pawn takes
takes played
develop this knight moves out of the way
and here bishop f4 is a nice tactic if
you find it
if you don't find it in just castle it's
not like white is worse black just has
a pawn for your activity right
so any questions now on any of these
lines
in the knight takes d5 nimso indian i
think i covered
pretty much everything that is that is
important
pip and truck says so what about what
about queen d4 you'll have to be more
specific
i don't know where you mean
i'm also not sure what steve north means
these questions